I said you're diving into this villain
role I feel like where that all was
birth was the series versus the Knicks
you hitting the shots you bow and every
time we shots you need to make you make
you making every play what I actually
think now is you are very much so a
showman but yet that's been flipped into
being this villain it ain't really fun
being a villain I don't dive into that I
kind of feed off the crowd if you were
listening to the game in the 10 minutes
left in the first quarter of game one
the whole Arena was yelling F Trey young
what do you want me to do like I'm just
hoping I'm playing I ain't said nothing
to the crying bout I ain't say as quiet
as F in here I ain't say none of that
yet I come out playing trying to win
trying to put on a show and I mean if
the fans want to get into it like with
the Boston thing like they started
yelling it in game five late in the game
I didn't say nothing to any Boston fans
I think they was all cool with me the
whole time and then game five when they
were up 3-1 that's what happened and
then we hit the game winner and that's
why I'm looking at them I really just
feed off of the crowd